hello and welcome to this video playing
Rex exa I'm going to go for this is a
red team probably just posing to a taraj
yeah it's a to rush and playing this b3
sideline let's see what Rex fir is doing
yeah we should I don't know do you think
why takes first then develop you'll see
one what usually gets a slight advantage
in those positions but blacks position
is always going to be somewhat valid
because of the the piece activity a
queen d7s totally ignoring would see one
like it doesn't mean anything
hmm so 95 he going he's going to take on
the f2 I guess okay
yeah we should have to say oh they
already move that makes any sense
check him and now lets him know 95 was
my idea going for going for the tech the
tech team of seven attacks d5 attacked
and all pieces are extremely active
again syndrome oopsie one a black
usually just just retreat said that the
Bishop on c5 okay I can just take a 6m
check now I have six is attacked I could
have taken directly but 1970
let's see a really good reply for black
and basically always take on f6
[Music]
but that says that's a pretty pretty
awkward pin isn't it the rook is
attacked and the bishop black resigns
yeah it was a bit strange that he
absolutely ignored Luke c1 I mean I'm
playing this rule for a reason and it
just played Queen to d7 I'm not sure how
strong Knight takes d5 really is in this
position but it's normal to just move
the bishop again so the engine actually
likes it
check yeah this this match you find
winds basically yeah it is it is very
active so check this is the line that we
had and white wins yeah so we have to
really question Queen d7 here even
though the engine gives 25 and this is
only slightly better for white this is
one yeah okay black as reasonably active
maybe he's somehow hanging on here but
check not funny yeah this move
there was another that was the game
Queen cheeks it's also also pretty
awkward yeah all kinds of things are
hanging yeah yeah I think you have to
react to look c1 somehow usually they go
back or something something like that or
we should be six but that this 9a form
in general and if black does not play in
94 here white should be slightly better
okay guys thanks for watching